finalement il ya eu pas mal de débats et
ce n'est pas terminé dans cette campagne
messieurs dames dont soir avoue un débat
sur la politique étrangère hier fort
intéressant devant public et je crois
que ce soit devant public on y reviendra
petit pot pourri vous l'avez peut-être
pas regarder petit pot pourri pour vient
tout de suite après vous savez il dit ça
il parle comme ça tout le temps comme si
le canada est un leader en matière
d'environnement
je pense qu'ils commencent même à se
croire réaction la réalité c'est que
tout le monde le sait que monsieur
harper n'a pas compris un élément de
base fondamentale que l'environnement et
l'économie s'avançant
votre réseau
alors voilà ça nous donne une idée du
temps aperçu général d'abord alec
performance des chefs hier sur ces
sujets importants mais ça ne fait
presque regretter qu'il ait pas plus de
débat sur les affaires étrangères parce
que c'est souvent un thème qui est ainsi
occulté dans les campagnes électorales
et là on avait des sujets forts
intéressants fort précis pss y avait une
bonne démarcation entre les différents
chefs sur la plupart de ces enjeux le
nom islamique sur les islamiques sur
l'environnement de l'aude la manière
dont on approche des relations avec les
états unis où straw mercy commerce donc
on s'adonnait aux gens une perspective
assez intéressant doublage les
différents chiffres
justin trudeau était très bon temps
manquait peut-être un peu trop en
retrait mais pas fait gaffe non plus
fils stephen harper a un avantage lui il
vient du g7 du g20 depuis dix ans et
préfet par ses fonctionnaires sur les
affaires étrangères depuis dix ans si le
premier ministre sortant donc c'est
normal qu'ils connaissent bien ces deux
aussi donc je pense que les trois choses
se sont plutôt bien débrouillé dans le
contexte chantal un débat instructif et
intéressant pour voir la performance de
chacun des chefs truc de nettement
meilleur que la semaine dernière un
débat qui probablement a permis à ceux
qui l'ont gardé de se rend compte que
les affaires étrangères c'est plus un
secteur de l'activité gouvernementale
fédérale c'est le coeur de l'activité
fédéral et saft à cause de la
mondialisation donc les grands sujets
dont on débat au parlement aujourd'hui
sont plus des sujets intérieurs sont
déçus l'extérieur et en le bus hier soir
avec ses lignes de démarcation je pense
que le commentaire que j'ai entendu de
plus soit en français comme en anglais
c'est justin trudeau moins surpris et
les gens ont trouvé que non seulement il
n'y a pas fait gaffe mais qu'il
maîtrisait ces dossiers là et qui s'en
tirait à ce débat là de façon inattendue
pour la plupart des gens je dis moi que
la veille au cas où
on attend d'un débat à l'autre que
justin trudeau s'écrase a pris fin il ya
peu près à cette heure et quart hier
soir puis c'était un terrain michel
peut-être pas miner pour lui mais ce
retard est peut-être plus difficile on
pouvait s'y attendre a été assez à
l'aise comme une chantal wii est la
principale chose à faire dans ce débat
comme ça c'est d'éviter pelure de banane
il n'y a pas beaucoup de bénéfices est
vue comme la gagnant il ya des grosses a
été en veine y en est vu comme le
perdant personnes s'étirait dans kg et
cela dit l'homme ce trio a très bien
performé
il a mené ce débat là de bout en bout
il a réussi d'une part à faire passer le
petit bout de vie sur l'environnement
est assez bon la faire passer vos
chargeurs dubaï rendu qui se croisent
les personnes qui nous qui nous qui nous
est servie t il se servir d'un côté du
qatar et de communicateur où le comédien
certains diront c'est un professeur de
théâtre le tout mais cela dit l'audace
al sahili il est celui qui communique le
mieux avec les électeurs et ça
paraissait ya semé sur les grands tours
la publicité kemball en désespoir de
cause c'est est ce que vous imaginez
vous cet homme ne nous représentent et à
l'étranger c'était comme le dernier
argument puisse espérer à certains un
contrôle on s'entend ce qu'on dit que
c'est à cause de son visage mais hier
soir ce genre d'argument la a été mis au
rancart d'un cas de justin trudeau
mais rappelez-vous l'éditorial du global
1000 quand justin trudeau ya plusieurs
mois il ya un plus d'un e même est avec
sa position sur les tests années que sur
on le disait confus sur les questions
internationales donc il s'est retrouvé
une logique
oui parce que justin bridou son premier
vrai défi était celui de la position du
parti libéral sur la guerre contre les
termes et le groupe armé al islami et il
avait échoué à se défiler l'automne
dernier se dit que même les ténors
libéraux étaient venus à sa rescousse
lors d'actions orties puis jean chrétien
non expliquée à la place de justin
trudeau sa position parce que lui
avaient été incapables de la mettra
clairement pour les électeurs en place
donc là il y avait beaucoup à perdre à
être encore perçu comme celui qui sont
les affaires étrangères et par la
hauteur visiblement il y avait été
beaucoup mieux préparé que lors du débat
de l'automne dernier
je suis fier de moi il a fait ses
devoirs sur cette question n'était pas
la chose qui était plus facile pour lui
au départ de toute évidence il s'est
fait griffer il est capable d'expliquer
ses positions et un rien de plus
dangereux qu'un politicien qui apprend
on
première mouture s'est posté 20 après
qu'il a gagné en 2006 ou en 2008 et
c'est le premier test un politicien
c'est pas est ce qui est bon quand tu
arrives c est ce qui est capable
d'apprendre et je pense que vous avez
dit chantal parce que le cliché 10 pour
les rouges étaient inégalement on ne
défait par gouvernement sur des
questions internationales
or les questions internationales
deviennent vraiment essentiel pour
définir au gouvernement fédéral
tu me partie importante jobs va aller ça
sert aussi à définir le chef quel type
de chef il veut qu'elle sorte de
principe qui va promouvoir sur la scène
internationale et sa est donc à
différencier les styles de leadership et
les gens votent beaucoup sur le style de
leadership tandis que willis des
programmes et dans une moindre mesure de
le savoir quel est le style de la
personne qu'ils ont présentée
représenter ce que je peux lui faire
confiance
les affaires étrangères c'est un bon des
marketeurs actuellement de sol est ce
que monsieur mulcair en ralenti son
érosion croyez-vous que quelques
effectifs parlez-moi de monsieur mulcair
jeu jeu parfois qui sait nuit hier soir
mais je pense pas que c'était des non
plus il a été même un peu arrogant
envers monsieur trudeau ce qui n'était
pas la meilleure idée des techniques
on est l'érosion à défaut à cause
d'affaires à travers la ville à cause
d'autres facteurs dont on va parler plus
tard alors je pense pas que celle là qui
a fait mai mais un petit point aussi
c'est même un peu à changer
fondamentalement ce qui est un assez
grand consensus canadien sur les
affaires internationales et c'est ça qui
a fait que le débat est intéressant ce
qu'on avait des philosophies
complètement différente
par contre sur le moyen-orient par
contre il ya des choses qu'on n'a pas vu
qu'on n'a pas abordé jamais on n'a eu un
gouvernement aussi proche d'israël à
l'histoire je pense que le mot israël au
président il s'est détourné il l'a
regardé la caméra puis oui oui mais
disons son palais le dessus alors les
eaux ne sont pas allés parce que sinon
pour dire que tous les partis je pense
et justin trudeau que le dit en passant
tous les partis au canada non non il y
en a été question qu'il serait et la
réponse était regardée nous tous il y en
a aucun des trois îles 6 mai c'est le
premier but justin trudeau qui
l'utilisent pour des fins politiques
électorales mais il n'y a pas de partie
si qui a mis dix lier pour il a dit vous
ne vous en faites une joute électorale
ici au canada le niqab vous avez tout à
l'heure vous avez dit michel c'est le
facteur qui explique l'érosion du gnp 10
au népal être occupés international puis
on sait pas si complètement le niqab non
plus mon jeu de ce spot c'est écolo mais
en tout cas on verra bien personne ne
sera mis le niqab savez vous combien de
femmes finalement ont demandé à être
reçus avec l'unique ngc la réponse parce
que votre recherche et ce malgré là mais
j'ai été très surpris moi-même de
l'année par ses doigts d'une main
c'était un thème de il ya eu deux cas
ce qui veut pas dire spawn discussion
valable sur un principe il ya eu deux
cas seulement au canada
or quelqu'un qui regarde notre notre
élection de l'extérieur doit se dire
ouais jusqu'à un certain point mais un
certain nombre de pays européens quand
même la france pour en nommer un seul
qui ait pas un petit pays qui a fait des
interventions assez musclée sur le
second
alors je suis pas convaincu moi qui nous
regardent drôlement parce que vous
regardez et des bas en europe de l'ouest
débat sur l'intégration d'une manière ou
d'une autre et sur les accommodements
à nabeul et un large débat de société
que le débat sur le niqab c'est un débat
sur les accommodements et sur le
consensus de ce qui est raisonnable dans
une société de droit
on a d'ailleurs essayé de poser la
question aux débats aux chefs au delà du
niqab
parce que c'est vraiment minorer ses
mines et monde-là du niqab est ce que
vous êtes prêts comme au québec à ce que
les fonctionnaires donne les services et
que les gens les reçoivent à visage
découvert et il n'y a pas eu de réponse
sur cet élargissement on est ce que ce
débat-là n'arrivera pas au canada 2 on a
dit on le dit principe un peu variable
parce qu on a posé la question à tony
clément une présidence conseil de 13 ans
quand ce débat sur le niqab est arrivé
l'hiver dernier en disant votre parti
veulent empêcher les sarments
citoyenneté mais vous seriez prêt ce que
font vos fonctionnaires servent le
public avec un niqab ou reçoivent des
services publics et unique appelée dwi
moi je très à l'aise avec ce donc le
gouvernement ait pas l'aise avec la
prestation de serment mais il est plutôt
à l'aise avec la prestation de services
les communes et cohérence là dedans et
là on voit qu'on marche davantage sur
les os du côté du gouvernement
conservateur
là on est plus près de la charte des
droits de ses plus d'idées licra ce qui
va se passer dans les fesses sexy avec
pas sa loi
ça va faire son chemin devant les
tribunaux la cour suprême va se
prononcer si la cour suprême valide la
poche québécoise
les pressions vont s'intensifier sur le
gouvernement du canada
oui sur les provinces mais à linverse si
la cour dit c'est pas de limites
raisonnables
au droit de la charte québécoise ou
canadienne en passant ça va finir dans
des bols très bien je veux absolument
parler des agriculteurs manifestation
sur la colline du parlement aujourd'hui
il ya des inquiétudes réelles que l'on
abaisse la protection pour les produits
laitiers notamment le lait le fromage
il ya une grosse négociations de
libre-échange avec l'asie actuellement
michel de perdre une transpacifique ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que le canada
est à peu près le dernier pays au monde
qui a ce qu'on appelle la gestion de
l'offre donc où les agriculteurs sont
assez bien protégé à fonction de leur
prix de l'heure de coûts de production
et israël et il ya la norvège disent les
producteurs laitiers du québec qui ont
encore à peu près la même chose
c'est certain que ça dans une
négociation des changes c'est sur la
table il ya quelqu'un qui veut dire moi
je veux faire un tri plus de mes
produits laitiers opl a demandé l'arrêt
de la marge est là alors est ce que le
canada est capable en ayant plus
d'alliés parce que quand quelqu'un cette
personne qui face à un peu plus de 10 à
la table pour dire ah bon on est
d'accord que vous gardiez ça pour que ça
reste c'est ça qui est la grosse caisse
os x certex avait dit que ça va être
possible à la fin j'ai ressenti si une
entente à la baisse cette semaine
cette entente doit être conditionnée aux
résultats des élections parce que les
partis d'opposition ont des positions
qui sont pas nécessairement un
synchronisation avec celles du
gouvernement
là dessus sur la protection de
l'industrie automobile donc oui on peut
toujours dire qu'on a fait une entente
mais cette entente là pas de valeur tant
que le gouvernement et lui dire la pomme
moi je vais signer la tuer c'est pour ça
que ça va devenir un enjeu électeurs
alex et c'est une question partout au
canada au québec producteurs de lait
entre autres l'un volet infante rôle du
sud de l'ontario québec est très
importante celle des oignons des
derniers pays avec la gestion de l'offre
c'est vrai on est un des pays qui
souvent sur le moins son agriculture
aussi c'est juste une méthode différente
de fonctionner les américains le jeu les
japonais subventionne énormément loring
l'industrie agricole c'est comme ça
qu'on les aide
plutôt que de contrôler l'offre et la
demande se sait une chose l'autre chose
c'est que les agriculteurs même ce que
touche pas énormément de compter en
nombre sur les 338 on s'entend et ne
peut être sept ou huit au québec c'est
une dizaine en ontario et sa guitare une
cote d'amour très fort dans la
population c'est eux qui amènent la
nourriture sur la table des citoyens 6e
10 ans vaut perd notre gagne pain en
circuit capable d'être
à la hauteur de ce que vous attendez de
vos agriculteurs en termes de fourniture
de nourriture l'oeil pour avoir un
dérapage en campagne électorale pour les
consommations voulait annoncer cette
entente là avant l'accord lots en parle
comme s'il n'y avait pas des gagnants si
le gouvernement est prêt à embarquer
là-dedans campagne électeurs c'est parce
que des gens et des groupes qui vont
gagner dans la société il n'y a aucun
parti en campagne électorale qui va
dessiner une entente où il ya seulement
des dégâts et des dommages dans le cas
de la gestion de l'offre je pense que
les conservateurs se disent on va offrir
en même temps un généreux programme de
transition pour essayer de faire taire
les critiques
idem avec l'industrie automobile mais
sur le pain et de beurre qui arrive sur
la table et le lait est l'argument
inverse de ce qu'ils disent il faut me
faire la gestion de l'offre et on fait
payer tout le monde trop cher pour des
denrées de base à cause du système quand
on nommer mais en même temps ceux qui se
font
qui ont un problème avec l'entente vont
parler plus fort que ceux qui vont qui
vont avoir des avantages de cet enfant
de cinq ans plus de temps de voir les
avantages que doigt des incohérences
ça me donne des ailes aligné depuis un
mois ils les ont mis à mal un poids qui
soit en même temps que d'autres pour
yahia qui vont applaudir pas c'est une
très grosse 135i pour applaudir la
saison on a commencé cette semaine
libélyon on travaille là dessus ces
dames c'est tout à condat merci toujours
un plaisir de voir un studio à l'humain
durable ou en ville à côté de moi demain
qu'à lui